the time has come to write the final
headline in the big news story in Santa
Monica the best picture award we've seen
film clips from the five nominated
productions during the past couple of
hours and here is a delicate beauty who
had the stamina to wait until now to
bring us the chosen one a former Oscar
winner of such beauty charm and grace we
can only call her one thing and that's
an Audrey Hepburn
well dear dear Bob I love you thank you
though
and I envy you what do you mean und what
a wonderful way you do this year after
year with such skill and such chain and
so effortlessly well confidentially
Audrey after every meal what honey don't
you get nervous no no actually I don't
but after every show I go into my
dressing room and faint retro actively
we already we have already seen the
excerpts from the five nominations for
this picture in alphabetical order they
are alfie a Sheldrake films limited
production paramount louis gilbert
producer a man for all seasons a
Highland films limited production
columbia fred winnaman producer the
Russians are coming the Russians are
coming the marish corporation of
Delaware production United Artists
Norman Jewison producer the sand pebbles
an argyle solar production 20th Century
Fox Robert Wise producer Who's Afraid of
Virginia Woolf a Chennault production
Warner Brothers Ernest Lehman producer
for best picture of the year may I have
a look
the winner is a man
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]